foreign
Rogers up in Denver Colorado Roger
welcome to the show
thank you Jade thank you George for
taking my call sure how can we help
well I want to open up an IRA in a
brokerage account so I can invest in
mutual funds
and I've heard Dave you know asked the
question do you want to pay taxes on a
thousand dollars today or a million
dollars tomorrow
you know so I wanted to find out which
one is the best one or the best tax
advantage is it's a great question it's
it's like an old riddle and there's so
many factors that go into this and of
course we're big fans of the Roth option
in general because it's going you know
you're using after tax dollars it's
growing tax-free but you withdraw it
tax-free there's no required minimum
distributions but it also factors in how
old you are so what is your age
57 okay and how much do you have right
now in retirement
oh
not much thirty thousand
do you have any other assets that you
would consider part of retirement a home
no
okay so you're renting right now
uh yeah okay I've been buying uh I own a
company I've been buying uh equipment uh
by buying uh commercial trucks and what
is your income on the road
uh right now it's about eight hundred
thousand a year wow my goodness hey I
have a question
what has kept you from investing up to
this point
stupidity
is I I didn't know if it was dead or you
know
no just you know at the end of the month
you always wonder where'd my money go I
don't have a big stereo system I don't
have big screen TV and all the CDs well
how long have you been making 800k
oh for
I'm gonna say about four years Roger I
just I just put a big chunk of money
into equipment Roger this is a wake-up
call dude you you make too big of an
income how much debt do you have
uh uh I just bought a truck it's a
hundred and twenty thousand and a
trailer for
thirty six thousand all right okay so I
just want to double check because you
said you own your own business the 800k
that's that's bottom line right like
that is pure profit correct
oh that's gross profit I'm gonna say
it'd probably be
around two hundred thousand okay that's
a whole different story so 200k is what
you're bringing home that's your net
that's what you're that's what you're
bringing home to buy the bacon all right
still an excellent income but you know I
think that you got to get your
priorities in line we got to stop
creating more debt we got to stop buying
new trucks you've got to save for
retirement it's it's creeping up on you
it's peeping and it's creeping and if
you don't make changes you are not going
to be ready I love that you're calling
in here asking about Investments but
there's some steps that you need to take
first in order to really set yourself up
uh to be ready to go and we gotta
eliminate this debt we need to walk out
these baby steps all right oh I will
that debt will be gone within by the end
of this year are you are you on every
dollar are you using a budget
yes okay sweet so you've got a plan to
win
yeah I've got it all planned out I've
got it down to how much money you know
could a penny would I make and how much
where everything's going good good I
know that by November of this year
everything will be completely paid off
okay so I just want to make sure right
now you're just looking towards the
future right because you know the way we
teach we're not investing until we get
the debt paid off and the reason for
that is so that you can throw as much
money as you're at your debt as possible
so you can get it knocked out so I'm
happy that you're doing research now but
I also want to reiterate it's not time
for that yet but let that yeah let that
light up a fire under your butt to keep
going and get this debt paid off with a
Vengeance you gotta move
so Roger are you is it just you in this
business
yes okay an option you can look into
because here's the thing with the IRA
you are 57 so you can you are eligible
for the catch-up contributions but
that's still only going to be 7 500
bucks which isn't quite enough to retire
on now you how long do you plan on
working for
oh do you want to retire someday
yes let's start planning for it
I wanted to retire 10 years ago and so
part of that is this debt is holding you
back from retiring because it's holding
you back from investing and stop
stocking away a whole bunch of money and
so my A1 is to get rid of this debt and
I'm questioning if you need this truck
is there another option because I'm
guessing this truck is for your business
right
well yeah it's a semi it's a a whole
refrigerated bibs is there another
option that you where you could sell
this truck and get a cheaper used one
uh no not at this
not at this time okay this is this is a
used one okay that I'm getting so the
ra1 is to use that 200 Grand income to
pay off this 156 Grand of debt which I
think you could do in under two years
that sound reasonable
uh by November of this year wow how are
you going to do that
I have no other day I mean it's just the
truck the car the cost of food okay so
you're gonna live on nothing is what
you're saying
right I love it I spend
I spend a couple hundred bucks on food
are you a renter or do you have a
mortgage
no neither I don't maintain a house or
so wherever the truck is that
that's home
the truck I just bought is going to be
I'm putting a driver in it
okay
so here's another thing to think about
Roger I want you working with an
investing professional who can help
guide this whole process over the next
several years to show you a plan and say
hey here's when you're going to be able
to retire based on the numbers we're
laying out and they're going to also
show you options where you can invest as
a person who's self-employed into
something like a solo 401K so that way
you have way more options than just that
Ira limited to 7 500 bucks that's right
and a good thing about that solo 401K
George is that you can do contributions
on each side as the employer and then
also as the employee so that's helpful
when tax day comes yeah to catch up
because you're you're obviously behind
on the retirement side but you have a
great income and I just don't want you
having to work for another 10 years if
you're even able to versus saying hey if
I can get this income up to 250 300 and
I'm throwing you know 100 200 Grand away
even if it's outside of retirement and a
brokerage account in a savings account
you'll be able to have a retirement with
dignity at that point which is my goal
for you yep
how's that sound and now did you say it
was the Roth that it has the best so
Roth is going to go in at with after tax
dollars grow tax-free at your with your
age it may be more beneficial to do the
traditional IRA and so that's another
thing to bring up with your smartvester
pro you can reach out to them at
ramseysolutions.com we've got them in
your area in Denver you can click on
Ramsay recommends and get in touch with
one of them to walk through all of those
options
and uh Roger one more question for you
the way your business is set up does it
require you working to bring in money or
is it something that you'll be able to
manage as you get older and have others
does that make sense delegate
yeah it'll be something that I can
manage because the the new truck I just
bought I put a driver in it it comes on
what the police on with the company good
basically they they keep that truck
moving I can go sit on the beach and
good good 10 trucks yeah I just wanted
to make sure that you had it I wanted to
make sure you had it set up in such a
way that you're not having to do the
brunt the hard labor as you get on up
there in age and that you can still
bring in some money and be sure you get
rid of this debt and then run that
business debt free Roger that is the
best path to a earlier retirement for
you we're wishing you the best man